Guillaume Michel vous êtes un modèle
pour tous les animateurs télé pour vous
c'est qui le meilleur animateur
aujourd'hui à la télévision
la performance je l'ai dit c'est pas
nouveau je l'ai déclaré il y a des
années qu'est-ce que j'ai entendu dans
les petits dîner parisiens qu'est-ce que
tu lui trouves à mais qu'est-ce que tu
veux connard
rendez-vous dans 2 ans rendez-vous dans
5 ans ça fait 12 ans celui qui fait la
grande performance c'est Cyril parce
qu'il fait du show il fait du direct et
puis il y va tous les jours tous les
jours tous les jours il y a pas toutes
ces prothèses qu'il y a autour il y a
pas il y a pas il y a pas un jeu de mots
à chaque phrase il a pas tout ça il est
quand même en liberté il est il est dans
sa catégorie quelqu'un qui
m'impressionne beaucoup je lui ai dit il
le sait il y a quelqu'un que j'aime
beaucoup dans le service public c'est
Cyril Féraud ah moi aussi je l'adore
parce que je l'ai dit souvent d'ailleurs
on se connaissait peu on s'est vu deux
ou trois fois je suis allé voir la
tournée Âge tendre
des gens de bois bon et bien il y avait
donc tous les anciens chanteurs revenus
dans la lumière des années après il y
avait un public de seigneur évidemment
j'y étais parce que tout le monde et
tous les chanteurs et quand j'ai vu ce
mot c'était présenté la tournée Âge
tendre avec toutes les mamies folles de
lui il y avait les mamies il y avait les
parents des mamies il plaît au mec il
plait oh mamie il pleut aux grands-mères
il pleut au mec qui suis là si s'il a
pas le Boulard il va aller loin et lui
je pense qu'il peut durer il fait
beaucoup de choses très différentes il
fait la carte au trésor il fait un jeu
c'est pas facile mon chouchou mais cela
dit dire souvent on pose la question
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire pour durer il
faut avoir de la chance nous on avait
une il y avait moins de concurrence
quand on débutait
mais il faut avoir un mental fort et une
puissante de travail supérieur à la
moyenne et un mental très fort et avoir
la chance d'avoir à ses côtés soit la
femme soit le mec qu'il faut on fait pas
sa carrière tout seul on peut pas c'est
impossible
moi j'ai à mes côtés une équipe en béton
et j'ai une femme qui connaissent mais
qui par cœur j'ai la tribu jarre autour
de moi parce que c'est la famille j'ai
mon beau-frère qui est en lui Philippe
Alain que tu connais bien je crois que
j'adore j'ai j'ai son fils Ludo Ludo qui
s'est occupé de toi une époque où tu
attendais la gloire voilà la personne à
qui je vois beaucoup et puis on peut pas
faire ça tout seul il faut avoir de la
chance une très bonne santé et un mental
très fort et moi la chance que j'ai eu
comme Pascal Praud comme deniso comme
Gérard Holtz d'avoir commenté comment
c'est comme reportage sportif c'est une
école extraordinaire c'est le direct moi
quand j'ai commandé cinq coups du monde
la première j'étais le plus jeune de la
planète c'était à Mexico la dernière de
Pelé qui est devenu mon copain après
j'ai fait 70 Mexico
74 en Allemagne avec 15h30 c'était déjà
bacon Bauer le patron ensuite je suis
allé en Argentine pendant la japanitaire
avec Platini il y avait un môme derrière
moi qui était furieux parce qu'il jouait
pas été trop jeune
en Espagne en 82 là où Schumacher a
failli décapiter mais j'étais là il y
avait Thierry Roland et je suis retourné
en 86 au Mexique et ma demande ma
dernière phrase de mon commentateur
c'est quand Louis se Fernandel nous
qualifie contre le Brésil le tir au but
mon petit Louise mon petit Louise et
ensuite monsieur Tessier qui était le
patron de France Télévisions madame
Michel en 98 il faut revenir
vas-y non j'ai plus canal est arrivé une
autre génération beaucoup plus fort que
moi il faut revenir je me suis posé la
question et puis j'avais l'impression
que je serai pas prêt pas assez bon puis
Charles Petry m'avait dit il faut y
aller platine il m'a dit reviens avec un
Consultant revient tu étais un bon
commentateur de foot et puis j'ai pas
voulu j'ai eu peur et je regretté parce
qu'on l'a gagné grâce à Zidane et des
sons ta femme elle regarde toutes une
émission ou pas elle te regarde c'est
vrai
de missions j'ai envie de la rencontrer
parce que c'est une [ __ ]
à la maison avec plaisir
avec plaisir habillé comme tu fais un
quartier
en plus et tout c'est vrai et regarde
toutes les émissions que tu fais toi
magnifique puisque je les connais sur le
plateau de Claude François et c'est
grâce à Claude François que je l'ai
connu ah je sais c'est que Claude
François
on est marié depuis 50 ans cette semaine
incroyable
[Applaudissements]